cuando tomas una clase de química
general normalmente tienes que memorizar
los nombres de algunos de los compuestos
poli atómicos más comunes vayamos a
través de una lista de algunos que
podrías ver en tu clase empezaremos con
un cateo nac y unión positivamente
cargado nh4 más el llamado el guión de
amonio y si nos referimos a uniones hay
muchos señores que deberías conocer se h
13 o menos es el ión de acetato
n menos es el ión de cianuro o h - es el
ión de hidróxido mn o 4 - es el ión de
permanganato y cuando comparas al n o 3
- contra el no2 - mira las terminaciones
entonces n o 3 - es un mi trato entonces
tenemos el sufijo ato que significa más
oxígeno en contraste con el sufijo hito
que significa menor cantidad de oxígeno
entonces podemos ver que el nitrato
tiene 3 oxígenos y el nitrito tiene 2
oxígenos y esa terminación es importante
porque va a ayudarte con algunos de los
otros iones poli atómicos
por ejemplo veamos el siguiente conjunto
de 4 iones entonces veamos el clorato
explorado tiene 3 oxígenos
3 - 1 y el cloro tiene menos oxígenos
tiene 2 oxígenos aquí cl o 2 - entonces
tenemos a pto que significa más e ito
que significa menos oxígenos y que pasa
con el perclorato aquí tenemos clorato
pero se añadió el prefijo per y el
prefijo per significa un oxígeno más
entonces perclorato significa un oxígeno
más que el clorato el clorato tenía 3
oxígenos cierto y para el perclorato
agregamos uno más y entonces tenemos 4
así que el perclorato es cl o 4 - a
continuación veamos el hipoclorito ya
hablamos del cloro aquí y aquí tenemos
el cloro entonces ponemos un prefijo
tipo en frente de él y pos significa 1 -
si vemos el cloro tenemos 2 oxígenos
1 ahora sólo tenemos un oxígeno entonces
este tiene que ser el guión de
hipoclorito
pudimos haber hecho esto para distintos
halógenos aquí estamos tratando con el
cloro entonces en lugar de cl o 3 -
digamos que tenemos
br o 3 menos
l 3 - es clorato pero aquí tenemos bromo
en lugar de cloro así que esto será
bromato entonces hay otro guión paul y
atómico y podemos hacer otro ejemplo en
lugar de cl o menos que es hipoclorito
podríamos tener de r
- que entonces sería y prometo este
sería
pero
tú
bien ahora veamos el siguiente conjunto
de iones poli atómicos entonces hagamos
algo de espacio aquí abajo tenemos ese o
42 - que es llamado sulfato tenemos la
terminación ato y tenemos 4 oxígenos si
tenemos 3 oxígenos so3 2 - esto es
sulfito porque esto significa menos
oxígenos y qué pasa si tomamos sulfato
que es ese o 42 - y agregáramos h más
entonces h más
con ese o 42 - debería darnos hs o 4 y
en lugar de un 2 negativo
12 - tenemos solo menos uno porque
agregamos una carga positiva entonces
una carga positiva con dos cargas
negativas nos da una carga negativa hs o
4 - el llamado añón hidrógeno sulfato o
también puedes haber escuchado sulfato
para este
el siguiente es 03 2 - es llamado
carbonato entonces si agregamos un h más
al ceo 32 - obtenemos hc o 3 y vamos de
menos 2 a menos 1 porque estamos
agregando una carga positiva aquí
entonces hc o 3 - el llamado hidrógeno
carbonato o también puedes haber
escuchado mucho que le llaman
bicarbonato a continuación tenemos pe o
43 menos que llamado fosfato y si
agregamos un h más al fosfato piensa en
lo que vamos a obtener vamos a obtener
hp o 4 y en lugar de 3 - como estamos
agregando una carga positiva vamos a
obtener 2 - y llamamos a este hidrógeno
fosfato muy bien ahora
agreguemos un protón al hidrógeno
fosfato agregamos un h más al hidrógeno
fosfato y eso nos da h 2b o 4 y vamos de
2 menos a 1 - entonces h 2 p 4 - el
llamado de hidrógeno fosfato
bien continuamos con un último conjunto
de iones poli atómicos por conocer
entonces tenemos cr o 42 menos que
llamado cromato y si tenemos dos cromos
es decir cr 2 o 72 - estoy llamado de
cromatos el siguiente ese 2 o 42 menos
que llamado jon de oxalato y tenemos
otros dos menos que llamado peróxido y
aquí tenemos ese cn - que llamamos yo
sea nato
entonces para ti o piensa en el sulfuro
si has visto el prefijo tío ah y para el
siguiente tenemos sulfuro presente de
nuevo es ese 2 o 3 2 - y este llamado
tiosulfato entonces podrías ver algunos
iones poli atómicos extra en tu clase
pero estos son los que se estudian más
frecuentemente así que asegúrate de
memorizar estos iones poli atómicos